can you hear me
please don't go where are you going
stem schmitz pop doir is nothing if not
seductive her latest single surrounded
me with your love is a cover and the
first single on her new album
the song is megan's to philly i came
across a song by chance i heard the
original by 311 porter on the radio
with your
untapped misdirected I fell in love with
it so I recorded my own version
sometimes music works like love you find
each other and something clicks the 26
year olds newest album is called raw
it's been four years since she released
her debut album femme schmidt that's a
long time in the fast-moving world of
pop
yes submission area I soon realized that
what I'm looking for is actually in me
sometimes there's more going on in your
head than in the whole world and you
need to take your time with things and
the spot emphasis on it said she took
that time to hone her craft when her
first album did well she embarked on a
lengthy club tour then she headed to
Australia touring as a support band for
Sir Elton John and making guest
appearances with Lionel Richie she
recently toured Germany supporting Bryan
Ferry you told my bryan ferry touring
with bryan ferry wasn't credible it was
an extraordinary honor to go on tour
with such a pop idol they were amazingly
nice to us and brian is incredible Brian
yes I'm from club respects it's been a
steep learning curve and finish MIT has
channeled all her newfound experience
into the new album recorded in London a
team of international musicians and
producers helped her develop her
signature sound
but my messin with my first album I was
more on the outside a bit like a voyeur
mad but with raw I feel like I'm in the
center of it all raw is all me it's been
written and raw desperation
and she wants your love to in March FM
Schmidt starts touring with her second
album